[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday August 30th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
compared with storing records in an old
filing cabinet digital storage can feel
unlimited and storing your favorite
pictures in the cloud feels more durable
than putting them in a photo album but
the hard drives behind digital storage
can break they can experience mechanical
failure or their formats could become
obsolete they can be harmed by dust or
heat or even something computer
scientists call bit rot but the speed at
which we're digitizing all sorts of
information isn't slowing down so how
can the world keep up joining us to
discuss that is Dr Brian Michael Murphy
he's the dean of the college at
Bennington College he wrote about this
issue for the Wall Street Journal and in
his new book we the dead preserving data
at the end of the world hi Brian thanks
for being here thanks for having me so
let's start with some background can you
lay out kind of how a hard drive Works
what's going on inside them
yeah so on a hard disk drive one of the
things that's happening is there is a
platter where the data is stored and
that platter is spinning very very very
quickly and it spins quickly when you
write data to it and it spins very
quickly anytime you want to access that
data and the data is going to be read
and then it pops up magically on your
computer screen but mechanically or I
should say physically what's happening
is that a microscopic level there are
little tiny bits of material that the
platter is made of and those little bits
each one of them holds a little tiny
piece of information that's either
positive or negative so if you've seen
The Matrix and you've seen all the ones
and zeros going up and down the wall
that's referring to how the computer
reads those magnetic charges and so
that's how it's made and so it has a
spin very quickly and it has to spin
very very smoothly for the whole process
to work I mean that sounds simple enough
but there can be these big problems that
run through it right I mean talk us
through what some of those are
yes some of the problems occur if
there's any kind of mechanical failure
that goes on with the mechanical parts
of the disc so there are ball bearings
in there those have to be lubricated
there's a reed right head that can
malfunction if there's any dusk like if
there was a problem in manufacturing the
disk and there's dust inside and it gets
in those components it can completely
ruin everything other challenges are the
things that have always plagued media
going back to ancient times right heat
even a microscopic form of Decay called
bit rot we think that like oh paper
decays or even film decays but you know
even metal uh decays after a long enough
time or it can even destabilize a bit to
where it loses its magnetic charge on
that point you've lost the data what
efforts are being made to address those
problems well what has driven a lot of
the changes in this technology over time
is the desire to store more and more
data on smaller and smaller spaces so
new data centers are being built all the
time but the problem is the form factor
of hard drives and actually the the
casing in which they're stored in data
centers that doesn't really change
there's not much flexibility around that
so you've got to figure out ways to
increase What's called the aerial
density of the hard drive storing more
in the same amount of space for the past
few decades we've done a very good job
of increasing the aerial density of hard
disk drives but those little segments
that the platter is divided into those
bits that I mentioned before they get
charged either positive or negative
they're becoming so small that they're
unstable so where if there's any
temperature fluctuation the particle can
misbehave and actually flip its charge
from negative to positive or positive to
negative and that's disastrous for a
hard drive because that means that
whatever data you wrote into that charge
is now lost so what's happening is uh
they're figuring out ways to create
platters out of harder material but that
means you need more energy to actually
write the data so they have like lasers
or microwave assisted Recording
Technology but the main problem is that
you can only go so small with those bits
and increase the aerial density so far
we've kind of reached that point so the
creativity is still there but it's
really really hard to innovate beyond
that so
get around this hurl I mean are we just
up
a wall and we're going to have to have
to start I don't know
how to filing cabinets and our like
cellophane photo albums again well I'd
be all for that because I love filing
cabinets and cellophane photo albums but
that's more personal preference I think
what's happening is there are a lot of
scientists who are trying to think
beyond the hard drive and the next
Frontier is really DNA data storage so
scientists have figured out how to store
the binary code the ones and zeros in
the proteins of DNA and that is the most
dense data storage material that we know
of a few years ago when a lot of writing
was coming out about some of the
breakthroughs that happened at Harvard
and the University of Washington and
Microsoft they said that the entire
internet could be stored in an amount of
DNA that would fit inside a shoebox and
of course DNA is can be dehydrated or
frozen so it could last for billions of
years if you're concerned about
permanence I gotta jump in here just you
know DNA it makes people think what
you're storing this in me in a in a
human what kind of DNA are we talking
about here so up to this point as far as
we know scientists have created
synthetic DNA chains in which they have
stored data it can be any kind of data
just like a computer you can store
something that's text based or image or
a video you can do that in DNA storage
scientists at Harvard also figured out
how to sort of insert data of a video
into a living E coli organism and we're
able to actually retrieve the video Even
after several generations of
reproduction in that E coli strain so
there are some other big dreams about
sort of dna-based biorecorders going
into people's bodies and things like
that but as far as we know that hasn't
happened yet and it's definitely not at
a point where it's scalable
what about manufacturing hard disks up
in space you know we've talked about
that on the show before we've heard from
experts that this is going to be a way
to more efficiently create hard drives
is this something realistically that
experts are turning to
well it's been a long-standing dream to
have a space where you don't have to
worry about dust or any other problems
arising in the manufacturer when you're
talking about Precision manufacturing
you can even go back to the Colonial
period America and watchmakers putting
their shop three or four stories up so
they were further away from all the dust
on the street because dust absolutely
ruins fine-tuned mechanical components
so the clean room is a technology is a
space where you've eliminated all of
that dust and that's where you know
microchips and all of these really
high-tech components are made so what's
appealing about space I think is that
there's a dream that space is kind of
like the ultimate clean room I think
right now it's a powerful narrative and
there is some funding behind it but I
think we're many years off from seeing
something like that actually happen all
right Dr Brian Michael Murphy from
Bennington College thank you so much for
joining us thank you for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you like this show how about
leaving us a five-star rating and
telling a friend about it and if you
want more Tech news check out our
website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
thank you